[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL PETERSON: I'm pleased to have with me, Jeb
Bush, the former governor of Florida.
And the person who saw tremendous gains in student achievement
while he was governor of that state.
And one of the things he did in that state
was introduce a lot of school choice.
Whether it was school vouchers, or digital learning opportunities,
or income tax credits that gave scholarships to low income students,
or charter schools.
And of all the innovations that have occurred,
the one that is really spreading most widely in the United States today
are charter schools.
So I thought I would ask the governor a few questions.
What do you think of charter schools, governor?
JEB BUSH: Well, I think they're--
charter schools, for those taking this course,
are, simply, independent public schools.
They have to take all comers, but they're public schools.
They just have a governance structure that is school based.
In fact, in the day, not that long ago, people always
talked about neighborhood schools and local schools
being the driver of a successful education system.
Somehow we've lost touch with that.
But that's what charter schools are.
They're run by, typically, passionate dedicated leaders.
And if they don't work, there should be some, and typically, in most states,
there's a process to close them down.
Now my personal experience about charter schools didn't start as governor.
I set up the first charter school with T Willard Fair, who's
the longest serving director of the Urban League Chapter,
of any Urban League Chapter.
And we built the Literacy Charter School in 1997.
PAUL PETERSON: Oh, where is that?
JEB BUSH: In Miami.
PAUL PETERSON: In Miami.
JEB BUSH: And it was the first school.
There were four schools that were created.
We had 90 kids.
It was one of the hardest things I've ever done.
There was real resistance by the school board.
We were forced to accept our contract in effect.
And you would've thought we were the greatest threat to the fourth largest
school district in the country.
These 90 children being taught, in uniform,
where parents signed a contract that said that they
would volunteer in the school.
PAUL PETERSON: But you were a cloud on a distant sky.
The sky was blue, but there was that little cloud out there.
You never knew how big it could grow.
JEB BUSH: So over time we changed the law
to make it easier for charter schools to be set up.
Many states, affective states, that have this
have a statewide authorization of charter schools.
We don't.
That was ruled unconstitutional in our state.
We tried that.
But now, fast forward from 1997, we now have 260,000 charter school students.
Many high performing schools, some that aren't as high performing.
And the beauty of charter schools is, if it doesn't work,
there is an obligation, I think, a duty to close them down.
They do this against all odds because they, typically, don't
get the same capital requirements.
And many times you can't share the space with the traditional public schools.
But I think it's a good thing because in a perfect system, the innovation that
takes place in any school ought to be applied in other schools.
The beauty of charter schools is they can innovate and try different things.
Unfortunately, the traditional schools don't embrace those changes the way
you would expect.
And they feel threatened by high performing charter schools.
PAUL PETERSON: There are, around the country,
some really high performing charter schools.
Whether it's in New York, or Boston, Washington DC, New Orleans, Los
Angeles.
So why is it that there's so much opposition to these high
performing charter schools?
JEB BUSH: Well, I don't think this is a conjecture on my part.
Monopolies are different than open systems.
Monopolies protect the status quo.
And government run monopolies protect it even more because they have more power.
And politicized, unionized, government run monopolies, there
are 13,000 of them in the country, resist change.
PAUL PETERSON: Why doesn't the public vote in a school
board that embraces the change?
JEB BUSH: Some places, they do.
In some places you have very progressive superintendents.
But that is not the norm because the system itself resists change.
And that's why charters, they flourish.
But it requires political leadership, and vigilance, to make sure
that they're allowed to participate and grow.
Ultimately, scale matters.
So if you have success academies, and in other charter management organizations
in New York State and City, for example, that have lights out test results,
irrefutable gains amongst low income kids,
taking kids that are lagging way behind and bringing them
up to averages that are as good as any school in the entire state.
That's what sustains these schools.
When you create a scale of parents that demand the quality school,
and you create a constituency around it.
But, in politics, a lot of times the adults
are the ones that the special interests care about.
And the adults in the system are the largest employers
in almost every county in the United States.
And so they wield big power.
But if you can get a constituency of moms and dads
that believe in these schools, and they do,
then they can be the counterweight to union leadership
that has disproportionate power politically.
PAUL PETERSON: Some of the leading civil rights
organizations have expressed opposition to charter schools,
saying they should not be expanded.
JEB BUSH: The NAACP has done that.
PAUL PETERSON: And yet, charter schools are serving the black community more
than any other communities.
So, I'm always curious about why that might be the case.
JEB BUSH: Well, it shouldn't be the case.
Rising student achievement is the civil rights issue of our time.
And you would think a venerable organization, like the NAACP,
would be on the side of children, and the families that want to get out
of failing schools and win the lottery.
Charter schools don't pick who they wanted.
They're not creaming off the top.
They're providing an alternative that parents desperately want.
And you would think an organization with a incredible history, like the NAACP,
would be on their side.
But they're not.
And they're not for reasons I don't quite understand.
PAUL PETERSON: So despite opposition, especially from the teacher union,
it is the case that 6% of our students are attending
charter schools around the country.
And it continues to grow every year.
Do you see a day when we're going to have a charter school
educational system?
JEB BUSH: I hope so.
I think there will be a point in time, and in some places like New Orleans,
we've already reached this.
Washington DC, it's been reached.
Where the scale, basically, means that you're not turning back.
That there'll be a melding of interests.
That public education will be defined by educating students.
And there will be choices for parents both public, and private, and hybrids,
both using online learning, and competency based learning,
and course choice.
They're going to basically get a menu of services,
and they can choose from it to meet the best the means
by which their child can learn.
That's where we're moving.
There's deep resistance to it.
But we would get far faster further if we moved to that basis.
Every successful enterprise empowers people to make choices.
That's called progress.
And when there's a tension, and when there's a choice, there's competition,
there's innovation, there's continuous improvement.
I mean, it's a fact.
It's not conjecture, on my part, in that particular case.
And education would benefit from this.
PAUL PETERSON: So I know you have a foundation,
The Foundation For Educational Excellence.
Is your foundation supporting the expansion of charter schools?
Is that one of your goals?
JEB BUSH: Sure, we support the whole array of school choice,
including charter schools, which is the largest option.
And we support accountability as well.
I think the combination of higher expectations, rewarding progress,
and rewarding excellence directly to the school combined with empowering parents
to make decisions, with quality teachers at the lead,
will yield a better result. Florida has done this.
And we've gone from the bottom to having some of the greatest learning
gains of any state.
PAUL PETERSON: So you would have charter schools,
but you'd hold them accountable?
JEB BUSH: Yeah.
PAUL PETERSON: Students have to take these tests.
They have to show that they're doing well on these tests.
If they don't do well, then you close them?
JEB BUSH: Yeah, look.
The idea, this is not to hurt traditional public schools.
This is to give parents choices so that quality improves across the board.
And if a traditional public school's not working that should be closed down,
if it's a chronic failure, and if a charter school miss appropriates money,
or has lousy outcomes for students, why would we want to keep it open?
Of course not.
Everything needs to be focused on one basic point, which
is a child is deserving of a year's worth of knowledge in a year's time.
And it should happen for 12 years.
And a child should graduate from high school
with a piece of paper that actually has value, which means that they are
college ready and, or, career ready.
In all honesty, Paul, based on your research and other people's research,
that I admire and respect, effectively, a third of our kids are college and,
or, career ready.
We better start training a lot of things to be able to improve them.
PAUL PETERSON: Well that is an disconcerting fact you just reported,
but nonetheless you've given us hope that the charter school
innovation will help turn that around.
Thank you, very much.
I've been speaking with Governor Jeb Bush, Governor of Florida.
In the period when the state of Florida was making the fastest
progress in American education.